hey guys it's max and vadim and today i
am doing
an unbiased blind camera comparison
we're gonna finally find out does vadim
truly love his iphone photos
or is he actually an underground pixel
fan let's see these things are a ton of
fun please get a piece of paper in a pen
or your phone out with the notes he's
going to be choosing
which photo he likes better he'll let
you guys know why as well
i've seen some of these not side by side
so i'm going to choose which one i
prefer even though i might know for some
of them it's going to get interesting
and i have no idea
and we want to hear you guys opinions
both of these are budget phones 350
bucks for the pixel 4a
and 400 for the iphone sc and they both
use older cameras with older sensors but
the software is newer on these phones so
let's see
which software is better and i took a
wide variety of shots
selfie uh regular photos even some
videos in panorama so we're gonna have a
really nice
scope of images and video for this first
photo
i'd say that i definitely like the one
on the left better because it looks more
bright
and not only that i like the color
balance better
and i see more detail especially on the
moose like
a bunch of fine details over there 4a
no right off the bat all right it's warm
we're not we're not biased at least this
far we'll see what happens oh wow that's
by the way if you guys like max tech
go check out our merch shelf down below
check out the masks
those are very popular let's move to
number two
this is a very tough call right here
because they're so similar
but to be honest i think i like the one
on the left because
it does very well with the high dynamic
range but on the right
everything looks a little bit washed out
or gray like
in those darks they seem like they
should be darker but they're not
and that one is the iphone s e
good job apple next one is
this i don't know why she put it i don't
know why she put it up so close here
well obviously the one on the left looks
better i mean you got the bokeh on the
back do you agree though
maybe you like this one better no maybe
you want to see all that's too much
stuff in the background
well this one you guys may have guessed
if you didn't already know the
iphone can only do portrait with people
and this is a situation where it's great
to have that portrait mode
and the pixel does it for this one i'm
definitely gonna go with the one on the
left because if you look through the
window
you have much more detail on that house
the car
everything and everything on the inside
looks better yep the sky is not blowing
out either so
definitely the left four
yeah it's interesting the iphone
actually made all this brighter than it
actually was
it was darker try too hard okay the next
one and this is
zooming in all the way um so i try to
zoom in and take a shot
with both and neither of these have
telephoto cameras so
well for this photo i definitely go with
the one on the left because
the goal is to zoom in more it seems
like on this photo and
you can read that text that meter
better on the left so that one and the
camera on the left zoomed in
a lot more than the one on the right
it's also sharper and that is the 4a
4a even though the sensor is i think two
or three years old now
from the pixel 3 the sensor is
impressive quite old
and then this is another zoom image but
instead of a lower light situation
it is similar lighting and i zoomed in
the same amount for both
this time around i'm seeing a lot more
detail on the right like especially in
the water
and in the building but i am seeing
noise in the sky
which is a little bit it's actually not
noise it's compression artifacts is it
frozen i think i'd still go with the one
on the right overall
on the right four
i actually thought that the iphone was
that one
because that usually the iphone has
artifacts and stuff in it
yeah but i guess not this is a macro
shot right here it took me a while
to try to get these because it's so hard
to capture them on these phones
well it's definitely the one on the
right the left is too blurry everywhere
absolutely
it was easier it was definitely easier
to take the image i actually did three i
think on these
wow and this is a portrait shot um
same situation using the portrait mode
honestly i think the one on the left
still looks better because uh the one on
the right is very flat
there's not much dynamic range and yeah
it's just brought up too high
the mids are 4a vadim you're a pixel boy
i like my iphone it's a pixel oh man
this is just a little too cool i like
the warmth on this side yeah
but it was in the shade so i guess it's
more accurate to what it was
yeah it seems like so and here we have a
shot of some delicious
food which one is more appetizing which
one do you want to eat
the one on the left of course i mean it
has more color and the plate on the
right is too cool it's blue
it was not a blue plate iphone for the
win on white balance
for this one and we have a low light
shot here
it was darker inside yeah on the right
for sure the one on the left is blurry
motion yeah and i actually took a couple
of these two
iphones so iphone is known from all the
tests we've done to have really quick
shutter speeds even if that means a
little bit more noise
definitely helped out in this situation
and we have our first video here
okay i know the shots last wasn't just
ugly so let's watch this video back
all right so right off the bat the one
on the left is super blown out
and even now it looks like the one on
the right has better
hdr better dynamic range and at times
the one on the left
your beard becomes fully black blacked
out
and that's the iphone what
that's the iphone honestly i was
surprised i saw this a little bit
earlier
i was surprised at the 4a dynamic range
it's a little flatter at times like this
because it's pushing the hdr a lot more
but look at this pause right here i
can't believe it it's hard to watch when
you're just watching
but too bright and his beard suit dark
pixel 4a for sure
and i'm surprised pixel usually had
issues with this but
yeah they i guess improve the video
software for this shot i'm seeing better
dynamic range in the sky
seeing more blue and in this texture of
all this stone work
masonry work i'm seeing more detail
there as well
so left 4a
i actually forgot to vote a couple times
and which one is my favorite so i'm
gonna skip that
yeah okay uh but you're you're the
important person right now and so far
the pixel is doing really good so this
is a wide shot here with a ton of detail
lots of light and the late i'm going to
crop in to see the close-up detail
without using the super zoom
algorithms they have uh what do you
think so far in this one
all right so it looks like there's
better dynamic range on the right
there's this little sign here that's
very white and bright and
it's better on the right side and you
see more texture in the sand
yeah it pops more more contrasty and
then this is the crop
okay yep definitely
the one on the right for sure get a
little more detail out of it too so
four four ah oh wow it seems like when
you need a little more contrast
yeah it's there but then when you need a
little more dynamic range
it's also there google impressive
they're doing a good job
and now we have a selfie with the sun in
the background
nice sunset what looks better which one
would you want on your phone if this was
okay you not me
this one is shocking because you're
getting much better dynamic range in the
sky
yes but the trees are so much more sharp
in the background yep everything's more
sharp and the foreground
and look at this flaring i wanted to
flare and i cleaned these off perfectly
less no smudger like yeah a lot better
wow oh come on
google how is this 350 that's insane
with
double the ram double the storage and
cameras like these all right let's let's
move on
and here we have two panoramas these are
white so i'm gonna go back and forth
take a look at this one let me know when
you want me to switch go ahead
there's the other one oh yeah the other
one the first one the first one's better
first one looks better
why is it better i don't know it just
looks better brighter overall
just i don't know yeah better contrast
the first one's the se is it the second
one is the pixel this looks
flat and colorless and detail loss it
looks weird
they have i wanted to test this because
google pixel phones have had issues with
panoramas
it's like three megabytes whereas the
apple one is 20 megabytes so they
really compress it looks like they still
haven't fixed that issue
now a nice sunset right after sunset
shot here yeah this one's obvious
left the left why do you like the left
one better i mean like
the one on the right like the one right
it's killed like the delicious here's
the trees everything's crushed
4a no how much do you have for the
iphone
four okay well yeah yeah we'll wait to
count and uh another nice sunset
different location here
wow the one on the left kills it so much
more detail
48 yep
all right and then this is already after
sunset
it's a nice night shot here and i i
rested the phones on a railing here
for this one i mean the one on the left
is definitely
nicer brighter i i don't really like how
this becomes so red
near the bottom of the trail like the
one on the right looks more natural
but to be honest i still like the one on
the left because it just brings out more
detail it pops like crazy
and the trees aren't crushed on the left
either here's one thing you didn't
notice look at all these compression
artifacts over here
okay on the sky yep and look how clean
this one is yeah
left 4a
wow this is going to get interesting
right now oh we have an inside shot of
my dog
i didn't expect that all right where's
my puppy look better
the one on the right i think i like that
one better 4a again i
oregon i didn't think the iphone shots
were this bad when we tested it i
thought it was good
what okay so next one uh
nighttime selfie just with my street
lamp
on from my house this giant lights do
you look mad
i was very tired this was late the one
on the left
yes um left 4a so the 48 could do night
mode
shots on the rear camera on their front
camera but
which it's a massive difference
and then my truck here yep left again 4a
don't forget to write it down a
compression artifacts
noise detail and then a close-up grille
i guess we could have got rid of this
one but
the one on the right it didn't use night
mode but the lamp is right here
looks just sharp sharper it's nice and
then
that tree the one on the right okay
maybe i shouldn't have put as much night
shots here but another one
left left for a uh look at the stars
and i didn't have a tripod here i just
rested on the grille which is why it's
kind of
the angles are off okay and then it
automatically went into astra mode and i
just kind of held it there while it did
its thing
uh the iphone doesn't have that and
this wasn't supposed to be here but yeah
write it down for a
i don't know we had two of those and
that is it that's the last and
apple tell says that they don't want to
put night mode unless the sensor is
capable of being read out fast enough
but this sensor is old look at the
results why won't apple do night mode on
these front-facing cameras that looks
like a great photo that you'd want to
keep
this looks like a photo you would just
want to delete basically so you guys
check your results if you've been pause
the video pause it check him out if you
kept track let us know down in the
comments your thoughts and what you got
vadim what did you get
20 for the pixel 4a and 5 for the iphone
sc
wow yes so basically we have our
conclusion um
first off we might want to make a pixel
shirt
well other than that if you care about
photo quality
go for the pixel i mean check out our
comparison between the two after this
video if you haven't there's a lot of
great things about the pixel
photos are way better and even the video
seems like it keeps up definitely not
with the 11 or 11 pro
but compared to this one it does uh
that's a great value for 350 bucks and
we'll leave a link down below
as well the iphone you have the
long-term usability
software updates a13 processors just
chip yeah but
photos are okay yeah in the pixel
good job good job all right guys thank
you guys for watching make sure to check
out our merch shelf
down below check out the masks if you
guys want to get one of those
and make sure you subscribe
notifications enabled if you want to see
our full review
of the google pixel 4a there's been max
and vadim
and we'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]